heroes it's an old-fashioned notion some
visionary from genius ensuring freedom
around the globe a symbol to the nature
a hero to the world the beautiful
shining out across the Stars
I look around at us you know what I see
a bunch of a-holes possibility
you think you know how the world works
the wound
is changing
need
heroes
very strength invites challenge
Challenge insights culture
culture
breathes catastrophe
the thing isn't beautiful because it
lasts
we're in the anger
before we're done
we still have one promise to keep
as you can't protect the Earth it can be
damn sure we'll avenge it
whatever it takes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
Marvel treated us to a brand new two and
a half minute TV spot this morning
now as you just saw it's pretty
nostalgic in fact most of the footage is
from the previous MCU movies in fact it
shows every single movie that exists in
the MCU in this two-and-a-half minute
clip it starts off with Iron Man and
then Captain America and then Thor the
original three Avengers and then it
shows every single movie in the order
that they came out so if you are looking
to rewatch everything in the short
amount of time if you haven't started
already Marvel just gave you the order
to do it however it wasn't all old
footage we did get some new footage as
well including an awesome new shot at
Iron Man in his new mark 85 suit I'll
break it all down in this video but
first if you're new to my channel be
sure to subscribe I'm doing a giveaway
giving away a life-sized Infinity
Gauntlet and a glow-in-the-dark painting
of fan oohs by globe I bow if you'd like
to interfere your chance to win all you
have to do is be subscribed to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain and I'll
talk more about the giveaway at the end
of this video so the first new scene
that we get is of Hawkeye rocket and war
machine and what looks to be the
Avengers headquarters what's interesting
here is that we're looking at Hawkeye
not Ronan he still has his bow and
arrows in this scene so it looks like we
only could be seen the Ronan persona for
a very brief moment in Avengers in-game
unless this is just CGI and he's
actually wearing his run an outfit in
this clip because since he's at the
Avengers headquarters this is definitely
after Natasha goes and finds him in
Japan when she goes and finds him he has
taken on his Ronan persona he still
looks like he could be wearing the
outfit still just has a bow and arrow
now instead of swords it does however
look like he has just been told some
pretty shocking news most likely
something that has to do with the
decimation and the Avengers dying
because rocket and more machine in the
background are looking at the floor very
sad and this does seem to take place
right before some sort of an attack
because we see rocket and more machine
together and we know that rocket and war
machine do a lot of fighting together in
Avengers in game based off of the
footage that we've seen from other
trailers and other TV spots so this
could be right before Thanos and his
outriders are about to attack the
Avengers
and then we have this awesome new shot
of Ironman in his new mark 85 Ironman
suit as he lands into this battle that
we've seen in other trailers and other
scenes we can see his new weapon appear
on his back and this is what they're
calling the Lightning Redistributor
essentially the suit takes lightning and
energy reabsorbs it and shoots it back
at the enemy so Thor could take as
lightning bursts shoot it at Ironman
suit and then propel that energy into an
attack they seem to be giving us just a
little bit more of Iron Man suit each
time we get a new TV spot or trailer we
then get a brief clip of Fanus ship the
sanctuary - coming out of the clouds in
space we know that Thanos ends up back
on his ship at some point in time in
Avengers endgame most likely after the
Avengers go and try to find and fight
Thanos in the very beginning of the
movie we learned from the footage that
Disney showed at their shareholders
meeting and that they showed at
CinemaCon that rocket and nebula
actually know how to track down Thanos
so if these trailers and TV spots are
sticking true to what Kevin Feige said
only showing the first 15 to 20 minutes
of the movie in the TV spots this is
most likely sometime in the beginning of
the movie where the Avengers go and try
to find and fight Thanos and then we end
by hearing Tony's old speech that he
gave to Loki in the very first Avengers
movie
it doesn't sound exactly like the way he
said it in the first Avengers film so it
sounds like he is saying it again right
before they go into the quantum realm or
into space saying that if we can't
protect the world will avenge it and
then immediately after we actually
finally see Captain America say whatever
it takes
we've heard the line a lot from many
different heroes but we've never
actually seen any of them say it and
that's it for all of the new footage
that they showed us in this trailer
I think Marvel is doing a great job at
keeping us excited showing us new
footage but not really giving us any
information about the movie still just
enough to get us even more hype to go
see Avengers endgame in ten days so let
me know what you think about this new TV
spot what did you think about the new
footage that we saw an Iron Man's new
mark 85 suit let me know in the comments
down below and again if you'd like to
enter my giveaway to win a life-sized
Infinity Gauntlet and a glow-in-the-dark
painting by glow by beau you can also
find other art of his at globe abode com
I'll put it in the description down
below all you have to do is subscribe to
my channel like this video and comment
down below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]